uh penny mordant is speaking first of
June consideration of Lord's message to
the strikes minimum service levels Bill
followed by if necessary consideration
of Lord's message to the retained EU law
Bill revocation and Reform Bill
followed by opposition half day 17th
allotted Day part one in the name of the
official opposition subject to be
announced
Thursday the 22nd of June General debate
on the infected blood inquiry followed
by a debate on a motion on the BBC's
proposals for the future of local radio
the subjects for these debates were
determined by the backbench business
committee
Friday the 23rd of June the house will
not be sitting
the provisional business for the week
commencing the 26th of June includes
Monday the 26th of June consideration of
Lord's amendments to the financial
services and markets Bill followed by if
necessary consideration of Lord's
message to the National Security bill
foreign thank you Mr Speaker and I thank
the leader of the House for the
forthcoming business
Boris Johnson lied
he lied to MPS he lied to the people of
this country he lied to nurses doctors
care workers bus drivers everyone who
was putting their own lives at risk
during the pandemic why does this matter
Mr Speaker because people sacrificed so
much and they deserved a prime minister
who values truth and honor
one who leads by example
and it turns out they didn't have one
as I read this report this morning and I
have I thought of all those people
including constituents of mine who
couldn't say goodbye as loved ones Lay
Dying because they stuck to the rules
because when they hear these headlines
they will be forced to relive their own
hurt and anger
I thank the committee members for the
thoughtful and considered work that
they've carried out over a year and a
constant intimidation from the former
prime minister and his friends they did
as we asked diligently and we should all
be grateful
I am disappointed to hear that the
attacks on them a committee with a
conservative majority a cross-party
committee properly constituted those
attacks continue today led by Mr Johnson
his behavior is shocking but not
surprising I was Shadow leader of the
house two years ago when he tried to rip
up the rules to save his friend
Patterson hundreds of Tory MPS voted
with him I'm afraid to say including the
current leader of the house and as we
don't know what the motion on Monday
will say I ask her now can she assure us
that there will be no such similar
attempt will she confirm the government
will give the house the opportunity to
approve and endorse the report in full
this all brings into question the
validity of Johnson's resignation honors
list and the prime minister's support
for it with a law breaker and a liar
rewarding his cronies will the leader
call on the prime minister to show some
leadership for once and cancel these
dishonorable honors
so on the prime minister's incredibly
poor judgment is he so out of touch that
he thought it was right that taxpayers
hard-earned money fund legal advice for
Johnson's lies to the public a shameful
waste of money during a Tory cost of
living crisis especially this was a mess
of his making
does the leader think this was a good
use of public money will the Prime
Minister now demand that Boris Johnson
pays back every penny now we will return
to this on Monday in full when I will
face the right honorable lady again
to a related matter Mr Mr modern Deputy
speaker a week really is a long time in
politics especially if you're the member
or is it the former member for Mid
bedfordshire because who knows she's had
a busy week apparently Bard from being a
baroness she then declared her departure
then threw a tantrum on tour TV
seemingly resolved her resignation and
launched a one-woman investigation into
why she didn't get a peerage
good now drug on for months like the
guest who outstays their welcome when
conversation has dried up she said she's
off home she's taking forever to put on
a coat and you know what she will stay
for that last cup of tea after all is
this really what people can expect from
Tory MPS so could the leader please
clarify is her colleague resigning or
not does she does she agree that the
good people of mid bedfordshire actually
deserve proper as a presentation from
their MB as Stu also the people of
Oxbridge and South ruislip Selby and
Ainsley and people up and down the
country who cannot stomach a moment more
of this Tory soap opera with a prime
minister too busy failing to get a grip
on the sleaze and Scandal engulfing his
own party to focus on the cost of living
on crime on NHS waiting lists with so
much to do and he can't even fill a full
parliamentary day what is the point of
him he is out of touch out of ideas
unable to govern he's breaking his
promises he's letting people down and
it's time he showed some actual
leadership and let the people have their
say and call a general election thank
you madam
leave with the house thank you madam
Deputy speaker well first of all can I
associate myself with the remarks and
tributes paid in this house to the
victims of the Nottingham attack and
their Brave families and friends and
also all those who perished are at the
grenfell fire six years ago and those
that love them this week we also
commemorate The Liberation of the
Falkland Islands and that is of
particular importance to many of the
families that it is my privilege to
represent
um The Honorable lady raises the uh the
issue of the hour and I think it is
worth reminding this house that the
Privileges committee
is there to defend this house our rights
and our privileges
the committee uh and the investigation
that They carried out was set up
unanimously by this house we asked them
to do this work the membership of the
committee was established again
unanimously by this house and as many
members have pointed out it had a
conservative majority on it I want to
put on record my thanks to the committee
uh and as my uh I hear from a sedentary
position yes members of that committee
doing uh their Duty uh my advice to all
write honorable and honorable members is
having had the committee carry out the
work we ask them to do is to read the
report
is to make their own judgments about it
and take the task that is our privilege
to do uh seriously and soberly and
members should use their own judgment on
that I can confirm that the motion
before us will be votable it will be
amendable
and it is House business uh and so I am
expecting a free vote and I know also
because the honorable lady reminds us of
previous uh previous case too these
These are difficult matters for the
house uh we have to look at the evidence
we have to look at the report but we are
talking about people who are friends and
colleagues uh it will be a painful
process and a sad process for all of us
the task that we uh we face on Monday
but all of us must do what we think is
right and others must leave us alone to
do so I concur with the with the
honorable uh lady
um the The Honorable lady understandably
has focused on wrongs and gongs if I may
say so
um but she will know that this
government has not been distracted from
its duties uh and she mentions the cost
of living I know how stressful and Frank
and exhausting that living from hand to
mouth can can be and we are determined
to support families and businesses
through these tough and volatile times
global economic conditions have been
made worse by the actions of those who
would do us harm the latest atrocity in
Ukraine will have knock-on effects
globally and as a country we must and we
will weather this storm that is why we
are supporting households on average to
the tune of 3 300 pounds it's why we
have frozen fuel Duty for the 13th
consecutive year why we have the triple
lock why we've had the largest ever
increase to the National living wage why
we've doubled the personal allowance why
we are capping bus fares and why we have
introduced tax-free Child Care
supporting 2 million families and are
expanding that offer further still and
the public need a plan from their
government to grow the economy to halve
inflation and reduce debt that's their
priorities and it's why it is our prime
minister's priority too The Honorable
lady will know that we are a resilient
Nation we have had the fastest growing
cumulative growth in the G7 for the last
two years the IMF have rev buys their
forecasts up and we have avoided a
technical recession which many said was
inescapable and this week we learned
that employment is higher than
pre-pandemic levels we've got four
million people into work half of which
are women and women in high skilled jobs
is up 38.5 percent since her party were
in power in tough times this country
doesn't need do mongers and hand ringers
it needs Fighters it needs grafters and
it needs hope Bringers it needs a
government that will back families and
workers and wealth creators and all who
invest in every sense in our nation and
that's what we are focused on most
notably during Tech week on the growth
sector of AI in contrast we know what
Labor's AI policy is anti-investment
anti-infructure and Innovation and
anti-individuals in 13 years of Labor
they managed to Electrify just 63 miles
of rail track their worst top 10 I.T
failures cost half the school budget
they had no free child care for under
threes they gifted us the fuel Duty
escalator and thought it acceptable
State of Affairs that someone when his
second job got to keep only 2p for every
additional pound they earned no labor
government has ever left office with
more people in work than when it came to
power AI isn't a danger to jobs and
wages a labor government certainly is
[Music]